should we be required to evacuate the
building when you please leave the
building by the nearest available exit
to the chain our assembly point will be
in the public car park on the side of
the Civic sweet these are do not delay
your evacuation to collect any
belongings please do not return to the
building until given permission to do so
by the council staff please note that
this being the meeting will be audio
recording would you please stop saying
interesting and here they're being a
chap is very narrow zone and our chief
executive I'm okay
good evening everybody and welcome to
this is the last chapter that I will be
taking in my ear office and our first of
all most like twice my chaplain was a
great etc oh good evening everybody here
to see it West counselor Specter are we
married I saw I was expecting you to be
all brawn start today good won a prize
at our fundraiser on Saturday the last
prize and it was a do-it-yourself time I
think I was sick a comment listen it's a
disappointment letter said the cancer as
usual tell you that story and all our
savings sometimes it's easier than you
think there was a film crew and they
were on location deep in the desert and
one day an old Native American Indian
went out the director and said tomorrow
rain and the next day it rained a weak
legs up he went up to the director and
said tomorrow storm and the next day
there was a hailstorm this guy's
incredible said the director he told his
secretary there and then to hire and
suggest to predict the weather however
after several successive predictions the
old Native American just didn't show up
for about two weeks finally the director
sent for him and he said to him look
I've got to shoot a big scene tomorrow
and I'm depending on you to tell me what
the weather's going to be like so what
will it be like the Native American
shrugged his shoulders and he said don't
know radio broke
and with that we'll pray Almighty God we
commend to you the upcoming elections
for the police and crime Commissioner
parish and town councillors and in
particular give thanks for all who serve
this district council in the past years
who will retire and those who will stand
again and those who may be newly elected
let their light shine to offer the best
virtues of integrity service and
diligence in serving our communities and
we remember to in our prayers and
thoughts the peoples of Japan and
Ecuador hit by earthquakes who have died
or been injured and those families
suffering the consequences of this
devastation may relief and help get to
them as needed and as soon as possible
and we also offer our prayers and thanks
to a match to the Queen on the occasion
of a Montieth birthday this coming
Thursday and as the longest-reigning
head of state of the United Kingdom for
all that she is given in service in
these past years to the peoples of this
land and for her unwavering commitment
to the Christian faith and its values in
particular of love for one another and
tolerance may your blessing and good
health be upon her now and always and
may your favor also continue to lead and
guide this company in all decisions and
discussions and the blessing of God
Almighty the Father the Son and the Holy
Spirit remain with us now and always
amen thank you thank you I like a nun's
in touch lately nothing congratulate me
yeah so yeah I'll do it anymore for me
no please the next we will okay so thank
you very much she's going at the next
one and what do you please don't be
seated
good evening everybody and I hope you
don't hear me tonight Oh apologies for
absence and now Josh now I've definitely
next to me if you with your apologies
for absence please I can chairman we
have apologies at the office from
counselors you are new this is Molly and
oakum thank you thank you very much any
other politician yes miss Castlewood
bears Chancellor Angela hi oh and you
the chance of it is canceled mathematics
and German go to decalgirl hand up any
way over here no thank you very much for
that and so item 2 is a medical meeting
held on the twenty-third of februari now
I any as anybody got me into saying it
is quite happy with it region free and
now I took three resourc and
declarations of interest is there anyone
anything to anybody thank you very much
and now I took door is an absence from
chair told me that our head of the paid
services it's okay the tips for me in
the year but I have been chairman in
authority I was very pleased when always
invited to be Trump the chairman for a
second time of asking and I remember the
yes I did and when my husband was alive
and we went out and it was a different
world friend how people worked have
people spoke and we didn't have
computers and all that sort of thing it
was all coming in this car around is
completely different the way the makeup
of areas are and have local government
what in a completely different way and
so when I became chairman i decided i
would have a project that i would do and
because what's good is looking to be a
tourist center I decided that during the
year if I can promote all the various
things that we have in rochford
profoundness and the all of the island
I've come through with the written the
two rivers and all the various places in
rockford with the church and the airport
and it's amazing with the airport if
anybody sees you with the chain on and
they ask you where you're from and I say
Rochford they say where's that I said
look do yourself their airport oh yes
it's lovely and the railway station blah
blah blah and then I have the greatest
of pleasure to say well the whole
parking two buildings have the whole of
that at the airport countdown to
rockford what for district council and
we are the authorities that are
responsible for it so that puts us in a
good state and also when we come over to
hotly and hockley woods and then Riley
with the windmill and of course now the
museum and then go to war with and go
down
hullbridge we have so much to offer
people and according to where I've been
can I bring all over a six so every part
of ethics well have been invited to
right across parts of lambda and into
sorry and Kent where people have you
invited me and I have been very honored
to go and represent this area but I have
been delighted to tell them about
rockford and what we've got in rockford
and it's amazing how many people now so
it can see here she comes from Rockford
and that go on about what we've got so
I'm very pleased about what I the most
important thing that I've done this year
is that I had the book opened here in
rainy and in rockford the people who
write a note to Her Majesty concern
being the longest reigning sovereign and
it was one of people put stuff in it and
instead of sending it off in the summer
I took it out with me for the various
meetings that might attained it was
across the district and in fact the
booking here by the time it was ready to
go had something like six seven hundred
people that have right written something
or put their name in it or from their
club and I was absolutely delighted that
that was there and also our officers
Chinese took the very nice pictures
across the district and they were
incorporated it in it as well and it
went off to Her Majesty as a christmas
card from Rochford District Council and
I was delighted because at the end of
January and it very nice less about them
Her Majesty's Secretary that department
thank you made and how pleased they were
to receive it and what I'm going to do
the letter I'm trying to frame it and
then it can go on exhibition not
necessarily in the Chairman's room
because not many people go in the chair
Truman up and you've been there by 14
thousand times in the year but so that
lesser is put as something that's
happened during my year above is for
people to see and I feel very direct
very Annika lap and now we are reaching
the stage where this council and how
it's creative it's going to change
dramatically and when the next election
comes up and it's going to have any
profound effect on the district in the
sense of stead of having 19 boards as
you all know and I've making the paper
sitting on the side to know that as well
so they understand but so now they may I
think new 33 member wards were coming to
be and I sincerely hope but whoever of
you are seeking reelection you find it
interesting and hopefully your dreams
will come true for the new council but
they're the people like myself there's
also i'm not seeking reelection so I'm
not here tonight I know college here
tonight with me is anybody else's not
seeking reelection a teen years and i
I'm sorry Jerry are you and I did wish
you well dear how to eat more um I look
forward to seeing but after the election
of how the wards are going to be made up
and what is going to be like at the
outside of all this is i SAT here this
is to twice I've been here but I've
sucking this council chamber for 26
years which is when somebody who might
going to be kids at school when I first
started it's only one person that can
beat me in that Chris and he was a very
young man then very young man what you
do and over the years I've seen the pits
are down in a Tropican red
and I've got sick what I can say is
Chris and I have SAT here and we've seen
people come and people go we see new
ideas come summer stayed somewhat
disappeared and also apart from um
actually think it's about you isn't it
yes I think you just here with me and
chris from the original not through all
those years ago and he was a young man
said but can I tell you he's always cold
war a bow tie I've never seen him
without a bow tie and it times open
there's been some beautiful ones over
the years the dear well i wanna i must
say in that over these years I've been
involved with the AL to as well we have
seen so many changes I came here and we
had to fix it that was up for check for
changes and recently at that time
instead of having roughly a thousand
members of staff because of the various
places that have gone out to tender and
other organizations taking over it gave
came down to roughly 500 people that the
staff and then cause when we got round
so 2002 that sort of period again that
was major changes and we've seen all of
these things come to go and it's time a
new things come in it's been very
interesting to see how coping with
reacted to it and to see how our
future's going and now to date as I
finish and now a new regimes going to
come new ideas of come in place already
and I personally be sitting not the
sidelines I'll be sitting down by the
seaside or somewhere like that and
having a good laugh when I think you're
here and hoping to not argue too much
because I won't be
join in but the other thing I would very
much like to say and I am now mr. chief
executive you did say to me I'll shut it
shouldn't say Matt but I'm sorry I am Oh
most important thing is none of us could
do our jobs without the stuff whether
it's a dustman whether it's my nice
striper or whoever it is all the staff
regardless of what they do they are the
people that matter the most because they
make what we want to do work and our
blaxican graduate some of you or all of
you for what you've done in the past I
personally want to say a very big thank
you I to Dave my driver and and John who
is now gone and also Emma who took over
and didn't come into position till about
June July so the first part I did on my
own and to all the stuff I'd like to say
a very very great they thank you for
supporting not just me that all of you
regardless out what you do it is the
staff that make it work okay ah so I
will shut up now and just say to every
one of you thank you very much to allow
me to be here to serve them that very
much thank you I can't you back you have
your hand up first the Chancellor couple
more wants to pursue level i'm happy to
be out of the father of the year
do you know something I don't know
there's my Oscar that's about um I'm
German yes you've been here 26 57 years
and he said I know you've had some bad
times and good times go into the hole
you probably enjoyed every month and
that's what it's about we're here to
serve the community machines here to be
on this equivalent I know we've had our
disagreements over the years sometimes
but profound screams oh yes but I wish
you well thank you and I'll just add
that I think the way out on the high is
you just spoke about in about six
minutes but you had little notes down
there but you were more fluid just about
ninety-five percent of the council you
bring up the high venture and wish you
would thank you very much Chris and may
I say to you personally thank you for
always when I vaniqa at you and
everything else it sort of come out and
with all good friends out which with
that is there and that's it thank you
very much for your support happy couple
thank you madam chairman chairman like
Chris I've been here 17 years now
believe it or not 70s always been my
lucky number for some reason but having
said that I'd like to wish you well I
think you've had a great year we still
wouldn't see you in the first council
meeting because obviously you've got to
hand the chain over so your part to play
with in that but after just like 26
years it's unbelievable that somebody
can actually be elected and have the
confidence of the public for that long
so I think that's a description of you
all the things that you've done and
there's not many people i think in
councils that and say that she had to
cherish it for a second time so I think
that recognizes the service that you
given but having said that as well I'd
like to wish everyone who's staying the
best of luck in what they're going
obviously I had my preferences but I
won't go into that I'd like to wish
everybody who's not standing the very
best of luck in their future endeavors I
know that everybody in this chamber who
is a member has actually contributed as
served and has actually helped Rochford
District Council to people it is today I
would like to thank everyone for that
chairman and having said that I'll sit
down but thank you very much for all
that you've done thank you very much
easy thank you thank you very much so
that that stops me from doing any more
there so that's number four and we go up
to number five questions from the public
is there any okay thank you very much
number six it's business or the last
chance to me p is there anything no
cherry doing why aren't we a number
server to note the minutes of executive
of their meetings held as anything on
that rock face no 38 to consider and
reports of executive and the committee
of the council that's our Spanish to
speak fury is my motivation gym at the
review committee it was Jerry yeah I
like it please leave it to play as much
if not well David please stay seated
thank you I'd like to move the whole
report of what I can't do is take credit
to the whole report to the loading
quality chair halfway through the year
to cheer responsibility and some of it
goes to counter the high for the work he
did hi Sammy be Jim have you said that
we've had some interesting items we look
council new homeowners policy and social
housing policy and very interesting the
last meeting I attended a twisted up in
comfy chair for developing now but we
looked at the council investments and I
have had a pre ignorance in I'm not very
up on the whole world of financial
services someone that won't go but a
couple of people on the committee know
it very well I think we were literally
surprised he told that thinking feel we
could double the amount of money that we
get from our investments and
consequently and even know about these
things well it'll be concerned about
what the ratio might be between risk and
the war in xyn are Mia look if you go
through greater rewards did dad open you
sometimes the greater risks and what
they didn't want this counter the dirt
was to be castigated for losing money
you know in a risky venture so we asked
the officers and they very kindly agreed
to put together a basket of the sort of
investments that we thought that they
wanted us to having the future and then
to monitor three months coming to see
how well it did and to also ask our
financial advisors to go back three
months so we had in theory six months
data so we could then come to this
council with a better understanding of
the ratio between risk and reward and
say issue a good policy oh it's not even
good quality I thank the obvious for the
work they did their reading pontiff you
can talk number people begging i read it
nice and good god develop money it
wouldn't be
me and then I'm very grateful if those
name was on the committee who know more
about financial services an idol and
would say whether they think you can
have got response to our concerns
anything doing they do I beg leave to
move the home port thank you thank you
very much but catford makes you mr.
management turn and I'm responding to
Jen review there were there were two
members who gave advice to the review
committee of which I'm one and i'm the
only one present so i thought myself to
stand up and we have had taken report
and a further discussion that meets the
parlance of our advice in particular we
will be looking at buying portfolios for
a period of time which will tell us
about volatility and will tell us
something about the bristol ingratiate
it will also tell us something about the
property fund which has been put forward
which we still have some interest in
getting further information on and I'll
do that so I can in that part of the
Review Committee's recommendation the
other part I really commend is without
going into detail because we have for
going to exempt to say that there is a
further recommendation that we look at
the added load evaluated by the current
treasury advice we receive nothing
sinister in that it's about time we
looked at exactly what we're receiving
and what we pay and how it fits with how
we're going forward so I commend both
parts on the recommendation
thank you very much anybody else wish to
speak counts it looks cute and half 1.1
you enjoy yourself and everybody please
for that two or three reach over and the
second one is 2.4 the bottom of page of
8.1 and there's other results there are
no in agreement with that thank you very
much I'm screen the reason so we now go
to our item 9 a report of Earth
decisions and I believe we have
everything up one counselor mr. Potter
yes okay Thank You chairman this is
effectively a report for noting by
counsel in accordance with the
Constitution thank you and if any
comments anyone please no I want to
believe them no injuries thank you so
much so now we go to item 10 and i
believe we happen to live in the council
here has got a report unfortunately i
don't even read it yet so as everybody
else trying to uh okay what have we got
more ok Jerry chairman this is my sixth
ordinary council meeting them for the
2015 7 60 meters per year I would like
to work with all members since the
council meeting on the twenty-third of
februari the executive met twice during
which we pointed the quarter 3 2015 16
revenue budget a capital position
the council approving the reasons for
variations to the previously approved
budgets noting that the latest net
revenue forecast returned as I aptor is
expected to be 8.6 a million for 2015-16
the canoes and wallasey neighborhood
area application was approved
consideration was given to a report of
the review committee on clinic
enforcement and the joint enforcement
protocol will be agreed with Essex
County Council and the environment
agency continuation of the amenity
collection services a great way for any
recreation ground on a monthly basis
collecting general refuse only was
agreed the exact report on exploring
options for delivery of the ground
maintenance service was received under
matters that my colleagues a nightly
executive of the demon we conclude
agreeing that the homelessness review
and critique of strategy 2062 21 be
approved in principle and circulated
consultation and noticing details of the
februari corporate scorecard exception
report as always I'll be happy to take
any questions from members and respect
of the work of the executive lunch
Almighty college will be happy to
contribute for appropriate thank you
very much anybody any questions please a
Chancellor mrs. Wilkins thank german
just like to thank you for the at the
refuse collection at went wakeling on
saturday at the first time that would
have it was well used i was down there
twice and it is very busy one time the
village is a very grateful that
thank you very much info do no thank you
very much minh and this chance to cut
more and i believe you will do 10 with
the new chairman not be next month this
time it's a paper very much for being
i'll fix it and I'm lattice follow the
stick sure that I think this year but
that's unusual number 11 notice the
motions for long term and number 12 I
believe officer if chemical war and
traffic thanks Jenna and this report
please to make arrangements for the
point will be many persons and parish
representatives and their turn concert n
commence filling in these four year the
Roger hundred will nominate three parish
members and my skin for council to
endorse those nominations come forward
decorative recommendation is to delegate
authority Musa monton officer following
a recruitment process to appoint
independent persons in persons and which
is required to the localism Act of 2011
and show me so much thank you very much
any questions for anybody no thank you
very much the recommendation is 710
place 12.2 are you all in agreement with
it this year
much and I now say and I think I've done
it ready huh thank you very much for
this evening thank you for the year and
all the things that I've done and I know
full well that in the coming year a
civic year when it comes into being
whoever you appoint as chairman I hope
but blaming enjoy and beat us it's
positive and hopeful but the work that
are quite agree and that they have a
good time but over the years I've been
here so I'm side with that take oh they
got a hardon for one rule don't block
and I'll sit down oh right i will close
the meeting there is actually completely
up staying for the Chairman k